let's talk a bit about anonymization
more specifically Onion Routing so max
has done a very good video on the dark
web and the Deep Web and the service web
and the differences between them when
people talk about the dark web they're
mostly talking about tor and
specifically tor hidden services now I'm
not talking about that certainly today I
might do that in a different video
tor literally stands for The Onion
Router right it is an implementation of
Onion Routing right which was developed
in the mid 90s by u.s. naval research
the idea is it bounces around
connections between different rooters so
that they're hard to track and it's and
it provides anonymity so this is
different from confidentiality which we
usually associate with encryption right
most of the time we're encrypting
messages so that even if people see that
we've sent a message we they can't read
what it is like but sometimes we don't
even want people to see that we sent a
message at all so what I'd like to do is
focus on Onion Routing specifically
bearing in mind but tour is a and
implementation of it so in some sense
I'm also talking about thought okay and
maybe we'll focus a little bit more on
what it is that tor does differently a
bit later there it is me and which is my
very well drawn computer as always and I
want to talk to a server here which
doesn't have a monitor because in my
view servers don't have monitors so
normally on this client server setup I
want to talk to a server but in this
case I don't want anyone to know that
I'm talking to a server at all I'd like
to be remain completely anonymous right
now if I then go onto the server and log
on obviously that's not anonymous
anymore right so it's limits to this but
this is the idea now how this works is
I'm going to bounce my connection around
and then it's going to go to the server
and if in essence the last node on the
hop but our pop on the network is going
to be the one actually visits that
website on my behalf a bit like a proxy
we're going to use multiple levels of
encryption to try and essentially
confuse people who are trying to work
out what's going on right now tour in it
in in its implementation uses three hops
three intermediate nodes so I'm going to
limit one that's not a very good
computer to analyze thoughts services
not monitors oh no so well I'll do I
mean
yeah so that's a good question right so
you can run tour and you can be an onion
router on a client machine on a laptop
you know it doesn't really matter if
your net connection is quite good you
can do it the software is free and they
very much want people to sign up and
become big intermediate nodes because in
some ways that's what the power tour is
we'll get to that a little bit but in
essence what happens here is I send a
message to to this guy he forwarded on
to this one he falls it on to this one
who then forwards onto the server when a
server responds they simply pass the
messages back now
this haven't really solved any problems
yet because anyone sniffing here will
know well ok we just need to sniff there
and in turn it's there and they can kind
of reassemble the communication it makes
it a bit of a pain but it doesn't stop
anyone from finding out what's going on
I even if these encrypted so what we
need to do is have multiple layers of
encryption what's clever about Onion
Routing
is that no one in this network knows
anything about the whole connection
they just know what's before them and
what's after them all right so let me
show you how this works so I'm going to
use different colored pen right through
this red pen let's imagine for a minute
that I've established some shared
symmetric keys with these three nodes
here right so just like in previous
videos where we talked about encryption
we're talking about let's say an aes key
and i have one shared with this guy and
one shared with him and one shared with
this guy no one else knows what they are
like because i used a key exchange to do
this so I had k1 k2 and k3 and this
Reuter knows k1 this Rooter knows k2 and
this Reuter knows catering now that
might seem implausible but actually
that's quite easy to set up using modern
key exchange right difficult for example
performance is quite well if I encrypt
something with k1 only this router can
see it all right and if I could crystal
k3 only this food you can see it right
there is no encryption with the server
at the moment now Onion Routing
essentially sends messages encrypted
multiple times with different keys in
layers so this message here is encrypted
three times right so this is where we
sort of far forward as I draw a bunch of
lines on but we're going to say this
risk with messages encrypted once with
k3 it's encrypted another time with k2
and when it's encrypted a final time
with k1 now let's think about what that
means it means that only this roots are
here could unlock the first layer that's
the first thing it means it also means
that when it's done that it's got a
totally garbled message but because it's
still encrypted twice already
right so it's gibberish it can't
possibly know what's going on but what
it can do is forward that message on to
K 2 so K 2 takes a message which is
encrypted by K 3 and then again
encrypted by K 2 and it can strip off a
layer as well but again it didn't looks
at the message and it doesn't make any
sense because it's still encrypted by K
3 so it forwarded on to this router
encrypted by K 3 finally k 3 decrypt
this message looks at it and it does
make sense because it's not encrypted
anymore and it and it says the message
says I'd like to go to Facebook please
and it goes I can do that and it
connects to Facebook and receives a
response now on the way back the exact
reverse closest happens this route will
add its encryption of K 3 and forward
the message on commuter - who will add K
to route 1 as K 1 and only we can
decrypt the whole message because we
have all the keys what's really
interesting is the property that this
gives us the first thing is that K 2
doesn't need to know anything except the
address of k1 and the address of K 3 it
doesn't need to know who I am right it
receives a message from k1 and all it
knows based on the protocol is this is a
message that needs to be forwarded to K
3 after I've removed my layer of
encryption that's all it knows when it
receives a message from k 4 e it adds
its encryption and then passed it
straight out the other door to root of 1
so if this was compromised by an
attacker they've learnt nothing right
they've learned that two of these guys
and running tor nodes or Onion Routing
nodes they haven't learned Who I am they
haven't learned who the server is
because both times is encrypted with
layered encryptions they can't remove
this is kind of gives you an insight
into what it is that's clever about
Onion Routing
they think about some of the other
things that it does k3 knows who the
server is because it receives a message
that said I'd like to go to Facebook so
it knows that someone on this network in
visiting Facebook and it knows that the
next hop is this chap this wheter here
it knows nothing else it doesn't know
who this client is it doesn't know who
Rooter one is so there's no
way for it to say our Mike's visiting
Facebook again right you don't let to
often because the way that the tour
protocol works you don't actually know
when you decrypt your lair
how many more layers there are there
could be 200 nodes and layers they don't
tend to be but they could be so the
output node only knows what's going on
on the server side and similarly the
input node my external is called a guard
node is only aware that this client is
browsing tor any messages it receives
are usually encrypted with two other
layers of encryption that it can't
decrypt so it just says well I've got
this message I need to forward it on to
this Reuter that's all I know right I
don't know but they're on Facebook I
don't know that they want to forum or
they're doing Amazon shopping I don't
know anything about what they're doing
so this is what taught us tor is in
essence an implementation of this
approach right so it has a protocol with
you know message lengths and structures
that are well defined in its
documentation that specify how you
establish these keys how you send these
messages how each one should decrypt
them and forward them on to the next one
but in essence what you do is this
client here will create what we call a
circuit which is this three hops by
first establishing a shared key of him
then instructing him to do the same and
then him to do the same and adding
extending the circuit each time they
want to with new nodes on the end and
every time I do that all the previous
messages have been encrypted so nobody
knows what's going on
so it's quite interesting it's slower
because really it's a lot slower like
you've got to consider that these nodes
first of all they might be they might be
serving a lot of clients at once so
there might be other cat keys shared
with other people coming in here and
leaving here and this one might be an
exit node sometimes and he's talking to
servers and browsing the web for people
and so yes you don't want to be signing
up to be an Onion Router if you haven't
got quite a lot of bandwidth also
consider that they may not be located
very close together right so this could
be in Germany this one in the United
States this over in Japan not really
important but a point is that it's
making you know large global hops which
take in the order of sub second but not
small amounts of time so you can expect
to wait a little bit longer for your
messages to get through all right start
the benefit you get is that no one knows
what what it is you're doing right we've
got a situation here where no one really
knows anything about what's going on at
all right which is very very clever and
has obvious benefits to people who want
to remain anonymous
now there's a few things we've missed
out it's a lot of things I've missed out
right because because the tall protocol
is quite complicated but this is the
general idea the first thing is that if
you go if you if you create this circuit
and then you just go to Facebook and
type in your username password and click
it you know that's going to give away
what you're up to
all right Facebook will know who you are
for start but if you go to a website
that's not even encrypted at all this is
sent in the clear lie so someone's
sniffing in at this point it me use my
blue pen for sort of eavesdroppers like
if someone's eavesdropping in at this
position they'll know exactly what
you're doing right and you type in
username and password then they have
your username password so you still have
to use TLS or HTTPS connections to the
actual servers right but that's really
on you once you've set up this circuit
you said normal HTTP requests and
responses to servers as you would
normally
it's just instead of it going through
your normal internet connection and your
normal IP router it goes through this
circuit and with all the encryption
happening so in actual fact the
implementation the Tor uses it works
essentially like a proxy you talk to
your own proxy server which handles all
this for you and then responses come
back so yes your web connection is a
little bit slower but for all you know
it's just a normal connection to a
server that's basically how it works is
really not a lot what morter than that
right and it's quite elegant and it
works very very well it's using tools
that like just installing a different
kind of browser
yeah you use a tor browser or you can
use it as a service and then you know
pipe armor fit other services through it
but tor is not illegal and nor til it be
it's just encryption there are a few
downsides right the first aside from the
speed the first is that people can sniff
on this network and start to get the
pieces of the puzzle the more positions
you are you know the more pieces you get
right but so if I'm sniffing here at
position a then what you see is you see
that I'm using tor you can't see
anything else if I'm sniffing here or
here I learn nothing right apart from
this encrypted messages going on tour
these onion routers are listed publicly
in the directory so finding
their identity is not a great concern of
mine if I'm sniffing a position be at
the exit node I find out that someone on
tour is visiting this website if it's
encrypted let's say using TLS then
that's all I find out the next question
that people be asking is what happens if
I control both a and B all right if I'm
at the front of the network going in and
at the exit node can I start to find out
what's going on and the answer is yes
right that's the weakness of Tor and
something that basically is unsolvable
apart from just to be very very vigilant
so how would this work well you've got
to remember that this is the big network
there's lots of users on it C is not the
only person talking to this router right
he's going to be the intermediary for
conversations the third node the second
node the first node
he might be an exit node he might also
be talking to servers there's a lot of
traffic going in and out like some of
which is tor some of which is not what
we're talking about is looking at a lot
of traffic coming from my machine to
this router and a lot of traffic going
from other routers to websites and
trying to correlate them and work out
what it was that I did right which is
not an easy job but you can imagine that
if you've got some time signature of
messages but let's say a sort of message
method message message message then
talking to this server coming out here
is going to be a kind of mess of lots of
messages but you might be able to find
the key points that match up with what I
sent in like that's the idea this
traffic analysis is the main approach to
essentially D anonymizing people if you
found that I sent 15 messages of a
certain size and a certain sort of tempo
should we say and then you found out
that those 50 messages came out
somewhere else on the network at the
same just shortly after let's say a half
a second after the exact same tempo
that's a little bit interesting they all
these layers of encryption let's change
the file size no which is a good thing
right this is cleverly designed with
that in mind
so tor messages are called cells and
cells are 512 bytes long they're always
512 points along the way that a Rooter
works out whether it's reading a message
or whether it needs to forward it on
it's basically based on a small hash or
digest that's held in the message
essentially it looks at the
in a message calculate the hash on it
and goes well I doesn't match the hash
I've got at all it must still be
encrypted because it's nonsense so then
it knows to forward it on C and it does
this by basically avoiding changing the
size of the message it will be obvious
as you say right if if three layers of
encryption added ahead of each time you
would know how far along the hops were
and the whole attack would be a lot
easier right so Onion Routing is based
around the idea that any message between
any node in the network looks like any
other message right it could be the
first one could the last one it could be
something in the middle right it could
have nefarious information on it it
could have perfectly benign information
on it impossible to know all right which
is really really clever there's a lot of
research on tour that goes into working
out how to minimize a chance for both a
and B are nefarious that's the idea so
this is why they sometimes call these
guard nodes because usually you select
some trusted ones and you only use those
for example we don't pick at random
because lots of